kylie cuoco says she'll never get
married again
guys the actress covers the april issue
of glamour magazine and inside she
reveals she's sworn off marriage and
doesn't plan to tie the knot ever again
yeah after two public divorces third
time's not the charm kaylee tells the
mad quote i will never get married again
i would love to have a long lasting
relationship or partnership but i will
never get married again absolutely not
i'm fine with that forever you'll
remember kaylee first got hitched to
tennis player ryan sweeting in 2013. i
love being a wife i love it i love it i
love it i feel like i was meant to be
but the two ultimately split in 2016 and
fast forward to 2018 and the big bang
theory actress remarried this time with
professional equestrian carl cook we're
having a bla carl's the best carl's the
best but after three years of marriage
the couple called it quits in 2021.
these last many months have been
tumultuous a lot of emotion so yeah
kylie might not be to the whole getting
married thing again but she's still all
about finding romance quote i do believe
there is someone out there i love love
i'm not someone that wants to be by
myself i just love it and that love is a
theme in her work up next kelly will
star opposite pete davidson in the
rom-com meet cute it's cute the movie is
so cute he's cute we had so much fun
he's hilarious kaylee says after
announcing her divorce she suspected
there'd be speculation about dating pete
but that never happened and we all know
now he's dating kim kardashian i am so
happy for him he deserves it he's a
total sweetheart so it's it's great and
when it comes to the 36 year old actress
one thing has never changed her passion
for her career this year marks 30 years
since your first acting credit
30 years that's crazy yes that is wild
oh my god i've been doing this way too
long what would you tell your younger
self beginning in those years about
where your acting career would lead you
oh my god i guess keep going and you're
going to be on e.t one day baby here we
are
keep on going don't stop on april 21st
we'll see kaylee starring in season two
of her hbo max series the flight
attendant i'm still a flight attendant
and i've been making better choices
i moved to la
met this great guy
picked up a part-time job
i kind of feel like i'm turning into
this whole new person
insane
we
are bigger and better than we were
season one and kaylee says filming
season two amid a divorce certainly had
its challenges but the cast and crew
helped her through saying the words i
need help
is the hardest thing for someone like us
you know we we help others like we take
care of stuff right and so saying that
out loud almost broke me and then i
realized how many people wanted to help
me and how much help i got um from all
different walks another coping mechanism
for kaylie therapy she says she started
going for the first time in her life
last year quote the hardest thing is
just accepting that i'm normal and that
i'm not superwoman i highly recommend
therapy to everyone out there even if
your life is going really well i can't
imagine life without it
[Music]